il a été élu le plus beau mec de France
parmi les 23 candidats sélectionnés
c'est Lenny c'est ça Morel ça va tu
étais content ouais franchement c'était
une belle aventure toi alors oui alors
je suis auto-entrepreneur oui d'accord
donc je travaille dans tout ce qui est
sport nutrition tout ça il y a pas comme
ton Miss France qu'elle est repartent
avec des paniers de chocolat voiture
ce sont des voitures
la fille il y a quoi pour lui donc il y
a des voitures il y a des parures
d'Europe il y a des parures de bijoux en
diamant il y a des
iPad ordinateur un appartement un
salaire pendant un an par rapport au
voyage
pendant un an et beaucoup beaucoup de et
des voyages et vous et moi je repars en
train avec ma valise
[Applaudissements]